les difficultés et les grandes choses que
j'ai traversées sont toutes construites lebron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
James
mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
c'est un joueur incroyable ouais, il est
l'un des  meilleurs joueurs du monde
euh sinon le meilleur joueur du monde
je peux imaginer avoir 16 ans et
avoir un enfant en deuxième année au
lycée et devoir élever l'enfant
euh tu sais par moi-même sans les moyens
sans le système de soutien
sans rien et donner à cet enfant
un sentiment de fierté, un sentiment
de force,
un sentiment de non-inquiétude
[Musique]
Parfois, les gens que vous connaissez regardent
leurs difficultés et
leur éducation, ils se demandent en quelque sorte pourquoi vous
ou moi savons cela  C'est très difficile et
c'est très difficile
et j'étais un de ces enfants à ce
moment-là, mais en grandissant, j'ai
réalisé que ces difficultés,
ces rues dans lesquelles je parcourais ces
nuits tardives, ces nuits difficiles, ces nuits sombres
sont en fait ce qui vous fait
[  Musique] c'est
vrai
[Musique]
tu sais parfois quand tu es enfant tu
ne crois pas que ton rêve peut devenir
réalité
[Musique]
tu sais que c'est un message à la famille euh
tu sais que
je suis désolé pour leur  perte désolé, vous savez
à sa femme
et vous savez que c'est de cela qu'il s'agit.
J'ai grandi dans un centre-ville et je connais
toute la notion de
sortir et de voter et j'étais l'un
de ces enfants et j'étais dans une
communauté qui était comme
notre  le vote n'a pas d'importance mais c'est vraiment
important il y a
moins d'un mois, j'ai pu
rentrer chez moi et ouvrir une école
dans ma ville natale
[Applaudissements]
240 enfants du centre-ville en troisième et
quatrième année
et d'ici 2021  nous devrions avoir 1 200 enfants
de la
première à la huitième année
[Musique]
alors
qu'obtenons-nous parce qu'en ce moment,
ce qui se passe, ce n'est tout simplement pas
bien
et euh, mais j'espère pouvoir continuer à
élever ma communauté, élever les communautés
partout en Amérique,
élever la  communauté noire, euh, j'ai dit
que c'est en partie la raison pour laquelle j'ai commencé
plus qu'un vote pour que
vous sachiez juste pour que les gens
comprennent à quel point nos voix sont importantes,
vous le remerciez simplement d'avoir sacrifié,
vous savez, tout ce qu'il a fait
pour nous faire entrer aujourd'hui et  même vous savez,
des années plus tard, pour pouvoir vivre ce
moment comme nous l'avons eu ce soir
[Applaudissements]
moi,
nous essayons de créer un changement, vous
ne pouvez pas perdre de vue ce qu'est l'
essentiel et pourquoi nous sommes venus ici,
oui, nous'  J'ai utilisé notre voix
oui, nous avons utilisé notre plateforme et
essayé de créer un changement, mais
vous savez qu'il existe une opportunité de se
présenter, parfois,
prenez simplement une profonde respiration et c'est à ce
moment-là que
vous